in the video on linkage institutions we
talk a lot about political parties and
the various roles that they play in the
political system in particular we talk
about how they are involved in
recruiting candidates and as we will
talk about in this video well think
about how candidates are actually chosen
to represent a political party and we
also talked about in that video on
linkage institutions how political
parties are involved in voter
mobilization which is a fancy way of
saying hey getting people to vote
getting people energized about the
election to actually get to the polls
sometimes going as far as getting buses
transporting them to the to the polling
stations and campaign management
campaign management and one thing that
is really interesting to appreciate
there's really the focus of this video
is that both of these things have
evolved over time so for example George
Washington the first president United
States he was not affiliated with any
party and our first two presidential
elections had no party association but
as soon as we get to the election of
1796 we start to see the development of
faction you have Hamilton on one side
becomes head of the Federalist Party and
on the other side headed by Madison you
have the Democratic Republican Party
Democratic Republican and there is a
nice irony to this because it was
exactly those two gentlemen that not too
far before 1796 if we go to the late
1780s in their attempt to get the
Constitution ratified in the Federalist
Papers they argue against faction howl
faction can be bad for a government for
a nation but they were the ones that led
this is split into faction and the split
into party and from that time for over a
hundred years all the way until we get
to the early 1900's early 1900s you have
some situations where the party
leadership might pick Canada
and some situation where the party
members pick candidates and conventions
and so you have party leadership
leadership / members we could say
handpick and pick
candidates so this part of the process
was not so broadly Democratic especially
when we get to the second half of the
1800s you have very strong party leaders
often called party bosses who almost had
the individual power to pick candidates
to represent one party or another but in
the early 1900's there was a movement to
say hey you know what this is not so
democratic to handpick the candidates
that people have to choose from and so
this is when you start to have the
direct primary system where to choose
the candidates that represent one party
or another you will hold elections and
those elections could be closed
primaries where you have to be a
registered Republican to vote for who
represents Republican Party or
registered Democrat to see who
represents the Democratic Party but they
have also have open primaries where
anyone can vote in the Democratic
primary or anyone could wrote vote in
the Republican primary and this is
happening to this day now this change
that has happened over roughly the last
hundred years you could imagine this has
changed the power dynamic between the
parties and the candidates for this
first over a hundred years the party is
where a lot of the power was but once
you start having the direct primary it
becomes a lot more about candidate
centered campaigns where things become
much more about the position and the
personality of the candidate then maybe
as much about the party platform and
because of that it has become more
common in the last hundred or so years
where even if someone is a registered
Republican they might vote the other way
or someone is a veget registered
Democrat they might vote the other way
if a candidate is particularly appealing
for example John F Kennedy was the
Democratic candidate for president in
1960 but many Republican Irish Catholics
voted for him similarly there's a group
of folks known as the Reagan Democrats
who are famous for despite their party
affiliation with the Democrats voted for
President Reagan and that was all around
this no idea that it was more about
the candidate especially at the
presidential level then it is about the
party
now just as how the candidate picking
process has evolved over time so has the
voter mobilization in the campaign
management in the early days a lot of
the voter mobilization in fact if we
think about the late 1800s where you
have this party boss structure you had
people sometimes going as so far as even
you know giving people things in order
to go and vote for one candidate or
another or exerting some type of
pressure the late 1800s or the second
half of the 1800s especially in places
like Chicago and New York where
sometimes infamous for not the
necessarily cleanest elections but as
you get into the 20th century especially
the second half of the 20th century and
now the 21st century things have become
much much more sophisticated so if we're
going to the 20th century you have
significant use of mass media mass media
and as you go into TV newspaper radio
and newspaper has always been a factor
in political elections going all the way
back to the founding of the United
States and then as you go into the 21st
century things have gotten a lot more
targeted obviously you can have email
campaigns you can start to leverage
social media and the 21st century in
particular things like email campaigns
in social media has allowed for very
specific targeting to voters what do I
mean by targeting well let's say you
really care about economic issues while
your cousin who lives across town really
cares about social issues the same
candidate instead of sending both of you
the same email might send you a targeted
message that speaks to what you care
about and this has actually become very
very sophisticated in the last few years
I'll leave you there but the big
takeaway here is political parties have
been around for a while in the United
States but they have been evolving in
this video I'm not even talking about
how their their platforms have evolved
and how their associations have evolved
but this is talking about how they have
evolved in terms of picking candidates
and how that has changed the nature of
campaigns and also how primarily through
the changes in culture and the changes
in technology how
about mobilizing and managing campaigns
has also changed